el alcalde de la ciudad de Miami Francis
Suárez se suma a la carrera para las
elecciones presidenciales de Estados
Unidos a través de un vídeo publicado en
sus redes sociales el político de 45
años ha confirmado que busca la
nominación del partido de repúblicano
para ser el candidato de los comicios de
2024 Suárez es alcalde de la ciudad de
Miami desde 2017 fue elegido Por poco
más de 22.000 votos y en 2021 fue
reelegido por una cifra similar de
votantes pero desde que ocupó la oficina
de la alcaldía trajo la atención de todo
el país cuando por ejemplo impulsó
políticas para convertir esta ciudad en
la que Residen unos 450.000 habitantes
en la capital del bitcoin llegando a
asegurar que gracias al mercado de las
criptomonedas los residentes no pagarían
impuestos algo que no ha sido así
también impulsó su propia moneda digital
La Miami Coin que se devaluó más del 95%
prácticamente sin valor también durante
la pandemia aprovechó para vender Miami
como el lugar idóneo para residir
diciendo aquí no se pagaban tantos
impuestos como en Nueva York o
California y tratando que grandes
empresas de silicon Valley se mudaran a
este lugar esto provocó que muchos
residentes de esos estados se mudaran
aumentando los precios de las
propiedades en más del 50% y provocando
una grave crisis de vivienda además se
sabe que el FBI lo está investigando por
un supuesto pago de 170 mil dólares por
ayudar a un desarrollador a construir en
una zona no permitida algo que sería
completamente ilegal la candidatura de
Francia Suárez ha recibido críticas de
compañeros de su partido del congresista
republicano Carlos Jiménez que fue
alcalde del Condado de Miami de que
abarca una mayor población que la de la
ciudad ha dicho que no votará por él
porque es un completo fraude que votó
por los demócratas hillary Clinton y Joe
biden y también por el candidato
demócrata a la gobernación de Florida el
partido de republicano tiene ya varios
precandidatos que están buscando
oficialmente la nominación incluyendo el
expresidente Donald Trump el gran
favorito según las encuestas el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis El
exgobernador de Nueva Jersey Chris
Christie y el ex vicepresidente Mike
pence entre otros